i never knew that this app would have
such an impact on people's lives you can
go into the description box click the
link for ios and android and build your
habit with the quran right now
video starts guys i've come together
with montana 8 to help those who have
lost their sight to see again just
imagine enabling these people in these
countries who are blind who cannot work
and can do nothing to see again may
allah give you guys that clear sight in
the hereafter that you have enabled
people to see in this life inshallah
please donate in the link below and then
why um does allah care about
i mean i don't know your beliefs that
well but for example
um that women have to cover their faces
good question so for example
we believe for example that god almighty
not has created us and he knows what's
best for us so as a muslim man so we are
men or human or higher than all the
other animals there yes yes we are so
therefore god almighty for example
when somebody creates something he gives
them money and he says in this manual
this is how you should use this product
for example when you have a phone they
say don't put it in water because it
might break
but almighty knows the best for us now
when women cover up in islam we believe
a woman should cover up except
everywhere her hands and her face
doesn't have to some believe the face
some but why i mean you have the manual
why don't you disagree let me tell you
why because for example
why do women choose to get their nose
done their backside done their breasts
done their hair done makeup wearing
skirts why do they find the need to
dress up in this way do they choose to
or are they forced to i think we should
ask your girlfriend
i mean she doesn't feel like she has to
okay okay no no no well if i can just
make this assumption for you
okay would you not agree societal
pressures the beauty industry your other
friends how you look beauty makeup
beauty enhances your beauty so therefore
we can't say that she chooses to wear
makeup or dress a certain way it can be
that society
same with a man same with men not just
women staying with men some men go to
the gym they try to get steroids to get
bigger
not because they choose to it's because
they believe if i look bigger girls
would be attracted to me so the
difference is this
a woman who wears dresses in a mini
skirt or wears a makeup and the woman
who wears a hijab they both have no
choice one follows what god said the
other follows what society says
so do you feel like you follow what
society says but that is more that is
more of like you can't really say that
you know why because beauty industry
it's a massive industry there's a book
called beauty sick i recommend your
girlfriend to buy it so beauty safe
talks about women are made to feel ugly
and that they have to look a certain way
do you know for example the
industry
um the beauty industry yeah yeah getting
your nose done do you know how many
people i know in my family who put their
noses done do you know they have to
smash your nose they have to smash it
put it together that is crazy to me why
would a woman choose to go to the levels
of getting a nose down her eyebrows done
a cheek style
breast on her backside done why so i say
because societal pressure has forced
women to look ugly feel ugly but also
you know islam says she is she has more
to offer than her beauty she is a human
being she can be a mother she can be a
doctor so much to offer my beauty why
only beauty that's why one of the
reasons why i want to cover this up is
because we are men we are visual
creatures but then allah cares about a
lot of
not that
important thing but he also doesn't care
about different things for example he
doesn't say which political system is
correct
it is an islamic political system we
have islamic political systems and how
does it work like he does
democracy or no no democracy okay
democracy democracy is a joke you have
three people that you pick which one all
of them have the same agenda and then he
does wrong okay next one next one is the
same thing i'm sweet i love democracy
are you studying democracy no of course
not okay what country from germany so
it's just yeah yeah
lady
so look what islam says is the following
islam says god almighty has created and
he cares for us he wants paradise for us
he wants us to have the tournament does
he create paradise with his rules with
his menu there always has to be the
quran is the menu
so we believe do you think that women
who live in
muslim women are happier because they
live by the quran well to be honest i
would say every woman and every man will
be more happy if they follow the quran
so for example
there would be you know what there was a
study carried out over 100 000 people
in from the 1950s to the 1970s and they
did a study in america and britain and
they look at the happiness between men
and women women are less happier
you know why because of feminism because
feminism has given this idea of you're a
career lady don't have children go and
work and then you have women now at the
age of 30 you cannot get married and
they cannot but due to their biology
they cannot they transfer their eggs you
know being fertile is less now they are
less happier so what feminism has done
is destroyed women and if you look at
women do you even women are more happier
why does a woman find the need to put
makeup before going outside why can't
you just go outside why why does she
have to get her nose done this is
oppression towards the woman
but it isn't like you dressing with your
but as a muslim man i have to cover from
my navel to my knee when i go swimming i
can't be topless no but i mean you you
have to dress as well and you it would
be more convenient for you to just wear
a t-shirt but you do it anyway no no but
why islam tells me that for example i
have to wear baggy clothes i can't wear
tight clothes yeah so as a muslim man
allah tells me in the quran tell the
believing men that when you see a woman
look away
look down why because it teaches muslim
men which is very important because we
don't teach we always blame the woman we
don't teach our sons to stop looking at
women in a sexual way you see a woman in
the bikini look away you see a woman in
a hijab look away you see a woman in a
cup look away
because we are visual creatures we as
men we get
visually stimulated so god tells us tell
the believing men to lower your case
don't look
so what that means don't sexually
objectify women and then what does allah
say to the woman you also know where
your gays but also cover yourself
i'm trying to say yes
why is that equality
look i was nice discussing with you it
was a pleasure i thank you very much i
really enjoyed it
my name is ali dawa i do videos on
youtube
um so so you can check one i'm kind of
famous now so you made it now i'm going
to sign a record deal you're going to be
at our records um
and yes to our sponsor yes to our
sponsor colgate for brushing our teeth
you can brush two times a day please
that's it
thank you don't forget you have to marry
her islam says if you love her you have
to marry her speak to her dad have you
spoke to a dad
you have to speak to a dad tell them to
speak to your friend
as you can see guys we are enjoying the
good of everybody and evil you know we
want the best for everybody to next time
where to come or there is everywhere
assalamualaikum